very exciting project that we're gonna  be starting next week and I want both of  you guys to be on it is that okay with  you yeah if I am not super diligent the  minute my face starts resting I'm a  [ __ ] come on cheer up  it's bagel day  okay just because I'm not smiling  doesn't mean I'm miserable he sounds  great he is great that's what I meant do  you think he's not great  sometimes my face has a really hard time  expressing excitement it sucks  oh hey did you hear about Calvin's party  it'd be so fun there's like it seemed  that excited about this  [ __ ] I'm excited I'm excited  Aaron we're a little worried about your  attitude you think you should smile more  stop saying that I'm pretty sure it's an  HR violation what's up when I first met  you you hated me you know that was kind  of offensive wait what's wrong what you  look like something's really wrong I'm  just thinking look this is just how my  face is okay  if this is about last night I'm so sorry